Last time.
We talked a lot about the idea,
I didn't,
I didn't mention the name of,
here's some jargon for you.
We talked about the idea of deleting dominated strategies,
looking at a game,
figuring out what strategies are dominated,
deleting them,
looking at the game again,
the heat we're strategists are now dominated,
deleting those and so on and so forth,
and this process is called the iterative deletion of dominated strategies.
This is not a great title of a Barry's book and you'd be better than that to get
the $250 right?
This is a boring title.
I don't mind.
Instructive deletion of domain strategies,
the idea of what it is,
it's embodies the idea of putting yourself in someone else's shoes and trying to
figure out what they're going to do and then think about themselves,
them putting themselves in your shoes,
bringing out what you're going to do and so on and so forth.
And last time we saw already that this is a very powerful idea.
All right,
and that game at last time,
but we also sorts of dangerous idea to take to literally that sometimes this can
get you to overthink the problem and actually as an that numbers game last time,
the optimum,
the best choice,
the winning choice,
it might not involve so many rounds.
All right?
We also saw in that numbers game last time that in some games,
but by no means all games and some games,
this process actually converges to a single choice in that numbers game,
it converged to one.
All right,
so just say once again what this idea is.
His idea is you yourself should not pay a dominant strategy.
Delete those,
delete those for all everyone else roads.
Everyone else is not going to pay a domination strategy.
Delete those.
Look at them at the game with all those,
all those dominated strategies deleted.
See if there are any strategies that are now dominated,
delete those look again,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
All right,
I could write that all up.
We saw it in practice last time that you were just easy to have the idea that,
all right,
one tip about this,
try to identify all the dominated strategies of all players before you delete
them,
delete.
Then look again to identify all the dominant strategies of all players again,
and then delete that process.
We'll,
we'll will prevent you from me from getting into trouble.
All right,
so today I want to be a little bit less abstract if you like.
And I want to look at an application.
I want to get a famous application from,
from politics.
All right,
so we're gonna look at a model,
all of politics,
all right,
and
the idea is going to be this.
We're going to imagine that there are two candidates,
two candidates,
and
what these candidates are doing is that choosing that political positions for an
election so that these are the players and the strategies are going to be,
they're going to choose positions
on our politics,
on a spectrum,
on a political spectrum.
You can make your life easy.
We're going to assume that this political spectrum has 10 positions.
So here are the positions,
we'll call them.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine and 10.
Right?
Very difficult.
All right.
What's the idea here?
We haven't finished tribe in the game.
Watch the idea.
The idea is that these positions are left wing positions and these positions are
right wing positions.
Can people not see past the podium?
Let's get out of the way.
All right,
so you could think of these extreme left wing positions.
These are people who,
uh,
I guess they,
they don't eat anything except for fruits and they think the tree should have
the vote.
All right?
And uh,
uh,
these guys out here,
these are the extreme right wing position.
So they think they think the poor shouldn't have the vote and they eat
immigrants.
I'm an immigrant.
I recap
the candidates here.
I'm going to try and choose positions.
We're going to assume this is not realistic.
We're going to assume for now that there are 10% of the voters at each of these
positions.
All right?
So there's 10% of the voters at each position,
so uniformly distributed.
All right?
And we're going to assume that voters will,
will eventually vote for the closest candidate.
Alright?
To voters,
vote for the closest candidates,
the candidate whose position is closest to their own,
and we'll need a tie breaking assumption and we'll do the obvious tie break.
If there's a tie,
then the voters split the boot.
Is that position split evenly?
All right.
The Thai,
half the voters go at that position.
Go for one of the candidates and half of them go for the armor.
All right,
so here's a game.
I've got the players.
That's the candidates.
I've got the strategies,
that's the political positions.
What am I missing?
Yeah,
I'm missing payoffs,
right?
I'm missing payoffs and it mangoes in this game a lot.
How we specify the payoffs,
but we're going to assume that the payoffs,
okay.
Oh,
that the candidates
aim
to maximize
their share
of the vote.
All right,
well,
that's not the only thing we could have assumed.
We could have assumed that all they really care about is winning and the winning
gave them a high payoff and that losing gave them nothing.
All right,
I'm going to spend a bit more,
I'm going to assume that they haven't spelt maximize,
right?
Max We'll do right.
They want to Max that share of the vote.
Right?
The reason this makes it this reason,
this isn't a terrible assumption,
is you could think of getting a higher share of the vote gives you a mandate or
if this is a primary election you want,
you know,
a larger share of the vote gives you a bigger push for the next primary
whatever.
All right,
so we're gonna assume that they are trying to maximize their share of the vote.
All right?
So we want to know what's going to happen in this game.
It seems like a pretty natural,
pretty important guy.
Okay,
so given what we've learned so far in the class in natural,
first question to ask is,
are any of the strategies here that are 10 strategies,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six minute,
nine,
10 right?
Any of the strategies dominated or any strategies?
Let's get some,
let me get,
my microphone is up and ready.
[inaudible] so any structures don't,
how about this gentleman in blue?
So stand up and stand up and shout.
Yep.
Great.
Um,
one in 10 are both dominated.
All right,
so,
uh,
this gentleman,
his name is Steven.
Steven says one,
and we'll come back to 10 but you're,
you're right.
We'll come back to 10.
So he says that straight.
That's position one.
Strategy one,
choosing the most extreme left wing position is a dominated strategy.
What dominates it by the way,
Stephen and a shout out to.
So for example,
I'll conjecture here is,
is that to
dominates
one,
two,
dominants one that's the claim,
right?
And let's just be careful here.
What does it mean to say that to dominates?
While it means,
it means that choosing position to always gives me a higher share of the vote,
then choosing position one,
no matter where the other candidate positions herself,
right?
It does not mean to beats one.
All right,
so let's take Stephen's conjecture and see if it's true.
All right.
It's one participant in particular.
Let's start working out what share of the votes you'd get if you chose position
one or position to against different positions the other guy can choose.
All right.
Uh,
okay.
So for example,
so what we're gonna do is we're going to test does to
dominate one and what we're doing this,
we'll figure out how these payoffs work as well.
All right,
well how about versus one?
I suppose the other candidate has chosen position one.
All right,
so the other candidate is chosen position one.
Then we're going to compare my payoff from choosing one against the other
candidates.
Payoff from choosing one.
We're going to compare this with my payoff from Tuesday to against the other
candidate choosing one.
All right,
let's figure out what that is.
So what's the,
what's my,
somebody can shout this out.
What's my share of the vote if I choose one and the other chooses one 50% that
was pretty easy,
right?
Must Be.
It's a tie for everybody.
So I'll get 50% of the votes
and what's my share of the vote if I choose to and the other candidates chooses,
one might have a center,
right?
In fact,
he will get,
or she will get all the voters at one.
I'll get everyone else.
So I get 90% so in this case,
choosing two is better than choosing one,
but of course we're not done yet.
We have to consider other possible positions of my opponent,
just oppose my opponent chooses to.
So now we're comparing my choosing one,
uh,
wet my opponent chooses to and the payoff I would get if I choose to wear my
opponent chooses to.
Okay,
so what's my payoff if I choose one and my opponent chooses to,
I get all the voters right on top of me at position one and she gets everyone
else.
Is that right?
So I get 10%
okay.
And what about if we both choose to 50% we're happy with that.
All right,
so 50% in this case and once again,
two did better than while everyone happy with that.
So we showed this choice was better and this choice was better.
I'm going to keep them going
against three.
So now we're comparing me choosing one,
my choosing one versus three and my choosing two versus three.
If I choose one against three,
what share of the vote do I get
all the people at position?
One and half the people at position two for a total of 15
okay.
And if I chose to as again,
if I choose two against three what do I get?
I get 20 again,
all people at,
why did I get all the people at too,
so I get 20% so we're okay.
Again,
let's do one more.
This is your pattern here.
If I choose one against four and comparing my choosing two against four in the
former case,
if I choose one against four,
how many votes do I get?
I get all the people that one at all.
The people at two right?
I get,
so I get 20% of the votes she gets.
Everyone else
had here.
I shoes two against four.
I get all the people at one,
all the people at two and what half the people at three.
All right.
So that comes out as 25%
okay.
And once again,
I'm sorry.
No,
I could go on right the way through here,
but I'm going to stop because it got to be a bit boring after awhile.
Right?
Cause I'm,
I'm,
I'm guessing you can see a pattern emerging here.
What's the pattern here?
What's the pattern there?
Somebody,
somebody,
somebody raised their hands.
I get in my account.
Then we get Mike in,
in,
in this guy in white.
Stand up.
Yep.
Sound up.
Spit up in one.
Start up and shouts.
Two is always better than two.
Has always been a little bit,
we can see more than that in the pattern.
What's the,
yeah,
that's right.
But what's the pattern here,
Mike?
Back.
Yeah.
Whatever is closer to five is better than what's ever farther away from five.
That's all quite the pattern I'm looking for.
Let's look at the numbers here.
We had,
we had 15,
20,
then this went up to 20,
25 and so on.
All right,
so what's,
what's the pattern here?
Yes.
Steven,
again hit.
If your opponent doesn't choose one or two,
then um,
then you're always going to be 5% better off if you choose to do in the morning.
Exactly.
So ignoring these first two positions are a bit weird.
[inaudible] choosing to always gave me 5% more votes than choosing one,
right?
Regardless of what the other person's shoes,
I mean you can,
if you want,
you can fill in the next whatever it is,
the next six positions and see.
But you'll see that very clearly that Steven's right,
that that choosing to always get me 5% more of the votes than choosing one from
here on down.
And in fact,
they'll go up in intervals of five.
So in fact it is true.
It is in fact true is we can conclude
include that too.
Dominates in facts.
We can do a bit better than that.
We can say strictly
dominates one,
right?
To strictly dominates you one.
All right.
Is anything else dominated here?
I'll just,
you've already told us that 10 is dominated.
I'm not going to go through that argument.
Can everyone see that?
Symmetric.
Hang on a second.
Can everyone see that 10 is going to be dominated by nine and exactly the same
way?
Yeah,
that was that obvious.
It's just really the same argument coming down that's coming the other
direction.
All right,
so similarly,
nine
strictly dominates
10 all right.
And again,
we're not saying choosing two beats,
choosing one.
Right?
Two wins against one or nine wins against 10.
Ryan was saying choosing to always does better than choosing one regardless of
what the other person chooses and choosing nine or is it better than choosing 10
regardless of what the other person's shoes.
All right.
There was a question we,
okay.
All right.
Let me get the mic and put the question.
Yeah.
Yep.
Stand,
stand,
stand.
Shout out everyone.
I think you may have defined it already,
but I couldn't find a definition of strictly in the book we have.
Ah,
okay.
Would you,
how would you have one on the handouts?
Let that,
I think the probably is one in there somewhere,
but just in case there's one this,
we've had two in class.
There's one on the handout.
Okay,
good.
Alright.
So,
okay.
All right.
So we've concluded that that one is dominated by two and 10 is dominated by
nine.
It's anything else dominated here.
Well,
what about,
what about thinking about
weather too
is dominated by three after all I've gotten your name but that um,
your,
what's your name there?
Yes.
So [inaudible] had suggested early on you want to be close to five.
So three is closer to five than to is to is to dominate saves by three.
That's true.
I ask anyone and anyone else who had any other hands.
There's a hand here.
Can I can't get this lady here?
Well,
once you delete the dominated strategies then you kind of go through it again
and then two is dominated.
All right,
good.
Just you're getting ahead of us.
Good.
So we'll get that,
hold that thought.
Hold that thought.
But what about right now before we delete anything,
let's,
let's check it out.
Let's check it out at two in particular.
Let's just try,
try this person.
The process.
So how about my payoff versus one for example?
So two against one gives me my 90% of the votes.
Okay.
Three against one gives me what?
85% of the votes,
which is actually lower,
right?
Just low.
So it's clear that three dozens dominate to write three doesn't dominate to in
particularly if the other candidate would to choose position one,
I would get a higher share of the vote.
Choosing to only would have done if I'd chosen three.
All right,
so in fact it's not the case that two is dominated by three box.
The woman whose name I that didn't get off of God.
So Christina's pointed something else.
The question,
when do you wait for the mic and point that out again,
once we know we know that two is not dominated and pick their not only by three
but what's the but
when you delete the dominated strategy of to dominating one or one being
dominated,
when you delete that and 10 than it is,
all right.
So what Christina is arguing is it,
even though it's the case that a two is not a dominant strategy.
If we do the process of releasing the instructions and we delete the dominators
strategies,
then maybe we should look again and see if it's dominated now.
All right,
so let's be careful here.
We're not saying that we're going to delete the voters at one or delete the
voters that 10 that we might wish to,
right?
We're just saying we want,
all we're saying is we know that the candidates aren't going to position
themselves at one and aren't going to position themselves at 10 so in some sense
we're deleting those strategies.
The voters are still let,
all right.
All right,
so let's try that.
So if we
bought here,
I guess bought,
if we delete the strategies
one and 10 which were dominated,
then
does three
dominate too.
And once again,
we can try it out.
All right,
so let's try it out.
so the payoff from choosing one [inaudible] start against to put power from
choosing two against two is 50% the payoff from choosing three against two is
what?
What's the from choosing three?
I'm gonna shout out with,
apart from shooting three against two,
eight
80% right?
The person at two's going to get all the ones that one,
all the ones at two or three we'll get everything else.
This is 80% all right versus three.
The payoff of two against three is all the people at one or two so it's 20%
the pay off from choosing three against three is of course 50% so so far so
good.
So far.
Choosing three is better against for the payoff from choosing two against four
is what?
What's the payoff from choosing two against four?
I got all the people that won all the people at two and half the people at three
so that's 25%
okay.
The payoff from choosing three against four it's going to be all hip at one or
two at all.
He went three for a total of 30% what'd again is bigger now?
Let's do one more.
First is five.
The payoff from choosing to,
I can't afford to raise this a bit.
Yeah.
Against five is all the people at one,
all the people at to add all the people at three
30% where's the payoff from choosing three against five is all HIPAA one or
table two or three and half the people at four
35% and again you can see exactly the same pattern is going to emerge here from
here on down.
I bothered to do it.
We'd find that choosing three always gets me 5% more of the vote and I would
have had from choosing to against any of these higher numbers are the same
pattern Stephen pointed out before.
So I've forgotten your name again.
I'm sorry.
So Christine is correct in saying that once we delete the strategies one in 10
once we realized that those positions are not going to be chosen by our
sophisticated candidates,
then we realized that probably choosing to,
and of course nine isn't a good idea either.
All right,
so two a nine
two and nine are not dominated.
Bought.
They are dominated.
Once we realize
one and 10
won't be played,
wouldn't be shy.
All right.
Okay.
So where are we going here?
Where are we going?
Where's this?
Where's this discussion?
And going to end up just going back to our original game.
Alright,
we've all used,
the one in 10 shouldn't be chosen because they're dominated.
We'd all get the,
once we realize there's aren't going to be played that two and nine aren't going
to be played.
What's in the,
what's going to end up being played?
Wow,
let's just go slow.
So we were able to donate one and 10 in the first rounds.
We know this won't be played and we know this won't be paid.
I remember the voters are still there.
I would just deleting the strategies then we don't need that.
Then we rolled out,
I'll put double crosses in the second round,
two and nine and then we rolled out three and eight
and then we rolled out.
We would have done four and seven and that leaves just five and six.
All right.
So if we do the procedure of iteratively deleting dominated strategies,
going back again and he wants dominated doing it again,
do it again.
All that's left is five and six.
So this procedure leads us to conclude that the candidates will choose positions
five or six just five dominate at six or six dominate five or anything like
that?
No,
at that point it's just a tie.
Right?
So at the end,
the procedure,
so intrusive deletion,
it's quite,
it's Dell
leads to deleting.
Oh,
except
except five and six.
Five and six.
All right,
so this was just a simple exercise I can run.
I mean,
I hope that was [inaudible].
Let me just look out there and everyone following that.
Okay.
That really wasn't meant to be hard.
All right.
But what's relevant about this exercise is not the fact it's hard.
Even if it isn't hard.
What's relevant is that it's relevant,
right?
It's about the real world.
I in particular,
this is a famous model in political science.
They want to know the name of this model.
What's the,
what's the prediction here?
The prediction here is that the candidates are going to be squeezed towards the
middle.
They're going to choose positions very close to each other and very close to the
center.
What's that called?
We all know.
Sorry,
hold the thought on that.
Hold on.
That.
So someone at the back shoulder,
this the median voter thera thank you.
Thank you.
That's a new board.
That's fine.
We'll be fine.
So the prediction is
candidates
crowd
the sensor,
and this is called in political science,
the median
voter
cetera.
It's called the median voter throne because the voters at the sensor,
in this case,
five and six actually get to decide not just election,
but decide therefore what policies are put in place.
All right.
How's this do as a,
as a prediction of the real world.
All right.
How does this do the picture of the real world?
Well,
there are examples in American history in which the median voter theorem looks
pretty good.
They're pretty old as examples are going to be before you guys were born.
But let me mention that anyway.
So I think a lot of people,
if you,
if you go back today and you look at tapes of the Kennedy Nixon election in 1960
so I'm American,
help me out here.
60 right,
right.
I think of 60.
So anything in the 1960 election between Kennedy and Nixon.
Do you ever look at those tapes?
Tapes?
It's amazing how conservative Kennedy looks when you think about his reputation
today,
right?
They really,
uh,
we're crowding the center and eight years later makes them seem to have learned
his lesson.
So if you look at the 68 election,
which Nixon won,
Nixon sounds almost tapes,
but his policies being put forward a mental action.
He looks extremely liberal for Republican.
All right?
So again,
they were crowding that center space.
Some people argue that that's exactly what Clinton did in 92.
He took the Democratic Party to the right eye towards the center in order to
pick up those,
those central voters.
And when shows are,
there are examples in American history of elections that seem to,
in which the median voter theorem seems to do well.
All right.
Now we'll come back and discuss it more in a second.
But before I do,
let me mention that.
The same model,
exactly the same idea has an application in economics.
Somebody mentioned already over the hell.
All right.
The application in economics is to do with product placement is the thing that
Jake's working on,
right,
and product placements.
You might think that is until placing a gas station,
you might think it would be nice if gas stations spread themselves evenly out
over the town or out over the road so that whenever you happen to be,
when you run out of gas,
there was a gas station close by.
That would be the convenience.
But unfortunately gas stations that we all know,
they tend to crowd into the same corners.
They tend to be on the same road junctions.
Right?
Why?
Because they're trying to,
they're competing for voters who happen to be close or running out of gas at
those moments and by crowding to cry crying together.
They've,
they avoid being out competed by each other in terms of position.
Can I said that a bit quickly,
but we'll come back and look at that idea in more detail later on in the class.
All right.
All right,
so in,
in,
in politics,
this is about crowding too close together towards the center to try and get as
many voters who are close to them and economics.
This is about firms crowding together to try and get a shoppers who are close to
them.
All right,
and the people associated with this are a guy called Anthony Downs who did this
in political science in a book in 1957 and then I can only makes a guy called
hoteling who wrote a paper about this in 1929 and in political science they call
this simultaneous discovery.
I think 909 is a bit earlier.
I have in mind,
all right,
now what I want to do now,
I want to do this periodically in the class.
We have a model out there and we've got to analyze it.
We've used a bit of game theory to analyze it.
I want us to talk about whether we think it's right,
what,
what do we think of the strengths and weaknesses of this model?
All right,
so I want you to show thinking about is do we believe this model list?
It's a good model of politics.
What's it missing?
All right,
let me come off the stage a second there.
I encourage you to get involved in discussion.
What,
how many of you policy majors now raise your hands,
your policy majors as well.
You've probably had,
how many of you are Polish ladies?
I've seen this model before.
Some of you have seen it before.
All right,
so a watch this model missing and you don't live in America or live in a
democracy.
I mean you don't know what everybody got.
A lot of you live in it.
A lot of deliberative democracy.
Do you have some idea about this?
What's,
what are we missing here?
So I'm gonna get the,
the woman here,
Ellie.
Yeah.
Evenly distributed.
All right,
so,
so one thing that seems,
seems odd about the way they start this model is that the voters are not evenly
distributed.
Let me,
let me go and put that up and I'll be a bit if retiring,
but let me go to and fro.
I bet.
All right,
so one thing,
what's missing?
Okay,
well wrong if you like on the one thing is the voters are not
evenly
distributed and the real world.
Okay,
good.
Anything else?
Good.
We'll,
we'll talk about each of these in turn.
Right.
Let me,
can I get the guy over here?
Sorry,
I'm not making this easy for the,
for to let me stay down here.
I'll,
I'll collect are fewer than,
go back to the board.
The model doesn't take into account differences between the groups in voter
turnout based on the candidates.
Good.
So,
so there's an issue of turnout,
right?
We assumed here that everyone votes it's not right,
but in fact not everyone votes.
There's always the option of not voting.
All right.
Remind me to put that one up.
It's okay.
Not Voting.
And it remind me of these hard.
The gentleman here in yellow,
there's a difference between the primary and general election.
Good.
So we,
we assume we kind of jumped to just one election and at least on the American
system,
for better or for worse,
I could voice it depended on that.
There are lots of little elections on the way.
There are primaries and all the states that you've never,
oh,
you probably have heard of the states you probably have heard of on the way.
All right.
Anything else?
Anything else that uh,
um,
can we,
can we get the,
where's the other mic?
Can we get the,
the,
the uh,
woman in green here.
American voters often vote based on character rather than position.
All right,
so,
so this more than just positions,
another way of saying that,
so to stop me if this is wrong,
but more want me to say that we've been assuming that politics is one
dimensional left,
right?
And there might be other things involved,
character or even among issues,
even on clinical issues.
It could be more,
more than one dimension.
It could be that there's a dimension about the environment and a dimension about
foreign policy and maybe another dimension about registering politics.
All right,
so there's a that's a,
that's an important idea.
Uh,
we got a couple of more years we got going.
Get,
um,
the,
the model might not apply with more than two candidates.
Good.
Good tone.
Now,
the issue here is I just assumed that there were two kinds of this.
All right?
We know in some of the actions there was a third candidate.
For example,
there was Nida in the,
in the election in a,
well I guess he was that another one as well,
but he was particularly there in 2000 so by the way,
I don't mean this as a joke and some sense there's always a third candidate and
that comes from the point we had earlier because not voting is always an option.
All right?
So in principle in that election in 2000 there was at these four candidates as
it were for things you could do with your vote.
You can vote for as it was then that time Gore,
Bush,
Nida or not voting.
And I'll leave it to you to decide which of those is equivalent to not voting.
Okay.
Anyone else?
No one else has.
One other thing I think was really,
maybe it's not small things,
but we're not really glaring thing here.
The glaring thing I bought was fine.
I haven't had yet click out.
I haven't helped me out here.
So let me get this guy here.
I'm extrapolating from the fact that there are different things which people
take into account.
Not everyone closes to six might actually vote for six and eight might be
covering certain.
That's true,
although that's,
that may be a question.
As I mentioned,
I had a different thing in mind.
I mean,
I,
let me say it.
All right.
So I think this is important.
Uh,
I've been a candidate could say during an election that I'm a moderate
candidates.
I'm at position five.
But you might not believe him or her,
right?
You've got the candidates track record in last.
That candidate can commit to policies at position five.
You might know full well that the candidate is in fact a position 10 or position
one candidate.
Is that right?
So unless the candidate can actually commit to a position,
all right,
there may be a problem in them simply announcing my position is moderate.
So again,
let's think of an example here.
Couple of examples.
Uh,
in,
in the Bush Gore election,
uh,
we saw,
President Bush candidate bushes saying,
I'm not a right wing candidate.
I'm a compassionate conservative.
And you guys believed him.
And I don't know,
maybe he was,
I dunno,
he's tracking.
I got in Texas,
I probably did actually look a lot like that.
Or today,
if you look at both,
primary is going on now you're seeing various candidates on both the republican
side and the democratic side seek to position themselves.
But as you all know,
those candidates almost all have track records.
And not everybody believes that Clinton,
that Hillary Clinton is quite so centrist as hip.
She now seems,
and not everyone believes that the former governor of Massachusetts is quite so
conservative as he now seems,
right.
So it's not clear that you can just choose your position Willy Nilly.
All right,
so let's put some of these up.
All right.
I'm,
I'm gonna Forget.
Let me see.
You have to help me out of beds.
So we have,
uh,
we have many candidates.
Yeah.
We have many candidates more than just two,
or we have not voting,
which is related to that.
Actually,
okay.
And we have,
uh,
choosing your position,
the inability to commit to a position.
All right,
so,
so your position,
okay.
Maybe not believed,
I don't want to claim that that's connected to the idea that you can't commit to
yourself,
to your policies.
Yeah.
And we had some others,
we had primaries
and we had a how other dimensions.
So we have higher dimensions.
Okay.
Have I got all that?
Have I got the main ones now?
I think I go,
thank God,
most of the main ones.
So there's lots of things.
When we look at this model,
there's lots of things I'm missing.
A lot of things are,
uh,
not seeming to be captured by it.
And here's why.
I want to get a little bit more religious.
You like,
it's tempting to say,
look,
we run at this model,
it's missing all this stuff.
So it must be useless.
Let's just,
you know,
we shouldn't go modeling.
You might even go further.
You might say modeling,
you're always gonna miss stuff out.
So let's just not bother.
And I think it's the wrong conclusion here.
The right conclusion I think is the reason we write down these models is to try
and capture and test our intuitions.
In this case,
the intuition about crowding towards the center to get votes.
But of course these models abstract from very important parts of reality.
And the next step to do is what is to say,
okay,
now let's try to enrich the model to add more into the model and see if you get
a different result.
And if so,
why?
All right.
So you start with your basic model,
then you add in,
you enrich the model and you see if the results change.
And that'll help you explain why you're getting different results in different
settings.
All right,
so the,
the,
the sort of part of today's class is models are always abstractions.
You want to use them to see what's missing and then add things back in to see if
they make a difference.
And if so,
how?
And let's go through these a little bit.
So it turns out that the very first one voters are not evenly distributed is
certainly true.
It's on,
that'll be true.
But it turns out that if you make the voters distributed more realistically,
let's stay in the kind of bell curve shape.
It makes actually no difference to the results at all.
All right?
So this is true,
but it doesn't actually change the result.
So this one,
we're okay.
Oops.
The results survives the uh,
this change.
All right.
What about the one about many candidates?
Well,
clearly that that matters a lot,
right?
We know that there are many candidates,
uh,
in,
in [inaudible] 92 election in the 2000 election and we know that not voting is
important.
So this one,
I'm going to let you see where that makes a difference.
This one's going to be on the problem set.
All right?
So I'm actually gonna get you to do this.
Let's go back to the model,
add an extra candidate and see what happens.
All right?
You can learn whether it makes a difference.
I'm not going to give it away.
The one that can missing to policy.
This is important,
is that it's really hard for candidates to convince you that they really are a
left or a writer or a centrist candidate.
Let me give you a historical example outside of America,
but in the real world,
in England,
uh,
in the,
in the 97 out in the,
in the eighties and nineties,
the Labour party in England had lost election after election after election and
in each,
and it would come forward and say,
we are not really a left wing party.
We're a centrist party these days.
And people would say,
we don't believe you.
All right,
so what Tony Blair,
the,
the guy who won the 97 election did with new labor policy was he managed to
commit to a centrist policy by literally committing to it.
He took the,
in England,
you have to publish your economic and financial plans or the government five
years ahead.
So he took the financial plans of the conservative government that was then in
power five years ahead.
And he said,
these are my financial plans.
I'm going to announce these today as my financial plans.
Five years said they're exactly the same policies as the conservative government
has.
[inaudible] choosing a position close to the conservatives.
He was choosing exactly their position and it came down to it.
Somebody else said,
here it came that left election on the other dimension,
which might've been character or whatever.
All right,
and that one,
that one by a big way.
All right.
So nevertheless,
even having give you that historical example,
we're going to come back and we'll look later on in the class at a model in
which,
uh,
politicians cannot choose their positions,
but rather you know their positions ahead of time.
So we'll do this one.
We'll do this one later,
right?
And these other two primaries and higher dimensions that both great points,
we're not going to have time to do them in this course,
but if you take a class in political science department,
uh,
on voting and on elections,
on a modeling elections,
you will see that both of these have been modeled and discussed in great detail.
There's even to empirical work on just how high dimensions are really involved
in elections.
All right,
so this is,
this is great stuff for this area of political science.
All right.
Tell me,
I want to inspire you to take some,
some more advanced courses,
albeit in another department.
All right?
So,
uh,
have I convinced you that this is something you can do with it or deletion?
Uh,
w we sweat,
we played it,
we use it,
a deletion in it ready?
Relatively abstract setting or not.
Absolutely,
but rather a place that thing last time in which we,
uh,
what would you was choosing numbers and then we looked at,
talked about it in t in terms of Hannibal Invading Rome and now we've seen how
it applies here in election game.
I think that's probably enough or deletion.
So what I want to do now is I want to switch course and introduced a new tool is
what we'll do typically in the cars.
We'll have new tools,
we'll see how they apply with it,
we can learn with them and we'll move on to a new tool.
All right.
So I'm going to switch to a new toy.
Any any,
any,
any questions at this point?
I ran out.
Everyone happy at this point or happiest?
Two strong people satisfied at this point.
All right.
Okay.
All right,
so we're gonna move away from this example and I'm going to introduce a new
subjects.
I'll need several boards,
I think.
Sorry guys.
We'll collect them.
All right,
so that bill semi religious speech about modeling,
I think economists,
those of you who are economics majors,
you're thinking,
yeah,
what's the problem for those of you who are history majors or political science
majors,
uh,
and that's more of an issue,
right?
So you really want to think about why we're modeling,
what do we,
what do we get for this exercise?
All right,
I want to move to a different approach now and
okay.
The different approach to analyzing games.
He's going to be about what we're going to call best response
had to kick.
Kick this off.
Let's look at an example.
Yeah.
So here's a game.
Very simple game with two players.
Play a one is choosing up middle or down and play.
A two is choosing left or right and the payoffs are like as follows,
then nothing really interesting.
They just some numbers thrown out for the purpose
for two and two threes that 510-TWO-ONE-3414,
two and two three.
All right,
so first of all,
let's try and analyze this game using the tools we've learned so far.
So does either player have a dominated strategy?
Can you take this?
So I claimed that neither player has dominated strategy.
Let's just check.
So for example is you might think down is dominated,
you really think down is dominated.
But if we look carefully,
we see that down actually does better than up against right and down does better
than middle against left,
right?
I have similarly we can see that right is not dominated because it does better
against up than those left but left isn't dominated cause it does better against
middle than does,
right,
right.
And so on,
so forth.
So you can work through this game and you can check pretty quickly that nothing
is dominated.
So if,
if the only tool I taught you in this class was dominating strategies and the
iterative lesion or donate his strategies,
we'd be stuck,
right?
We're going to get,
you wouldn't really get started on this game.
Nevertheless,
it's a pretty simple game,
but straight forward game,
imagine your player one in this game.
You'll play a one in this game.
What do you think you do?
What would you do if your player one?
And so it's a show of hands actually.
So,
uh,
let's just see how I look at it.
A base,
right?
No extensions.
How many of you would choose up?
Yeah,
raise your hand for opera.
Raise your hands right now.
Somebody put to keep your hand out.
You're at SRMC.
You keep your head up.
Oh,
you're Martha is wrong.
Okay.
You took accounting last year.
No one's choosing up.
I don't want to.
You put,
okay.
How about middle one person chose middle.
How about down?
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
There's a massive majority for down.
All right,
so let's think about this a second.
What if you knew that player to was going to choose left?
What would you choose if you just happen to know that player to was going to
choose left?
Okay.
Oh everyone agree?
Because,
because five is bigger than one and five is bigger than four.
So op is to use a technical term.
We'll define formal next time.
Oh is the best response to left.
Everyone agree with that?
All right,
so up,
let's say does best
against left
and what does best against right
middle does best against right after all four is bigger than zero and four is
bigger than two.
So middle does best against,
right?
Okay.
So here's an interesting thing.
All of you chose down but opt does best against left and middle does best
against,
right?
Let's,
let's push this a bit harder.
I suppose that you work for somebody.
Some of you going to go out of Yale and be your own boss,
but most of you are going to like me.
I got to end up for somebody and suppose you play this game came along in your
line of work and you'd chosen up and then your boss came to you and it looks
rather fiercely asks you.
So this is Rick Levin or somebody looking rather fiercely at me and says,
why didn't you choose up?
Right?
And what can I do?
I can say,
Oh,
I chose up cause I thought the other guy was going to choose left.
Right?
I have a way of rationalizing choosing up if I believe the other guy going to
choose left,
I can rationalize choosing up that right is that might save me from getting
fired.
At least for now.
Similarly,
if I'd chosen middle and uh,
President Levin comes along to me and say,
why did you choose middle?
I can say,
okay,
I chose middle because I believed that the other guy who was going to choose
right and middle was the best thing for me to do against.
Right.
And once again,
if I'm lucky I will get fired.
It seems like I've managed to rationalize choosing middle,
but down all of you shows down pretty much all of you chose down.
Down is going to be a little tricky.
How am I going to rationalize choosing down?
Can I rationalize choosing down?
You will chose it.
I'm your boss now.
Why did you choose down?
Somebody hasn't said anything yet.
Can I get the mics up?
And perhaps the person right in front of you stand up and shout.
It's the safer answer.
If you can't decide whether or not your opponent's gonna choose left or right,
you don't have to worry about having a payoff of zero.
All right?
So in some sense it's safer.
It avoids the zero.
Although,
uh,
I mean it's true to voyage to zero,
but it doesn't always doesn't get the five and the four.
But,
but I think the key part of your answer was I might not know.
I might not be what?
Be sure whether their opponent,
whether my opponent is choosing lefts or rights,
for example,
I might believe that it's equally likely that they choose left and right.
Is that right?
All right,
so let's look at something.
Let's look at my pay offs from choosing the three options up,
middle and down.
If I think it's equally likely that my opponent will choose left and right.
Okay.
So we're gonna look at is the expected expected
hay off
of up
versus let me hold it half,
half,
half off being equally,
equally likely that my opponent chooses left and right.
So what's my expected payoff from choosing a op where,
where I believe the other persons are gonna choose veteran,
right?
Equally likely it's what?
It's a half times
five
plus a half
times zero for a total of two and a half.
Is that right?
All right.
What about my expected payoff from choosing middle against a half half.
So in the,
in this case where I think it's equally likely that my opponent's gonna choose
left or right.
All right.
So in this case,
my expected payoff is a half
of one
plus a half or four
for a total of again,
two and a half ever happy with that?
My math correct so far.
All right.
And how about my expected payoff from choosing down versus a half half?
This is going to equal
a half of four plus a half of
to which is a half of six.
So that's three.
Alright.
So turns out that as the gentlemen out there said,
if I thought it was equally likely that my opponent was going to choose left or
right,
then actually my best choice,
my best response is to choose down.
Right.
Or is it a good compromise on is it safe?
It's actually the best I can do.
It maximizes my expected payoff.
Right.
All right.
Now we're not quite there yet.
We know that up does best against laughing or the middle of those best against
rights and we know that down does best.
If I think it was equally likely that the person's gonna choose left and right,
but that's not the only beliefs I can have.
For example,
I couldn't believe that it's twice as likely that the person's going to choose
left as right.
Right.
It could be,
I think it's they're twice as likely to choose laughter's.
Right.
So equally likely it was problems of half the half.
What problems are associated with being within cancer twice as likely they're
going to choose left than right.
Well,
proteins are associated with that two thirds.
One third,
right.
I think if I thought there was two thirds,
probably they choose left and one third property,
they choose rights,
then I think it's twice as likely they're going to produce who's left.
And I could redo this calculation.
And in principle,
I could redo this calculation for every single possible problems that you can
think of.
Right?
But that would get very boring.
So rather than do that,
let's draw a picture.
Yeah.
What I want to do is I want to draw a picture here.
All right?
In which on the horizontal access,
I'm going to put the probability of the other guy choosing reits,
right?
It's my belief that the other guys going to choose,
Think of this as a belief.
Okay.
I don't the vertical access,
I'll put two vertical axes in just for the sake things
on the vertical access.
I'll put my expected payoffs,
my expected payoffs.
Right?
And let's start by considering my payoffs on his pictures,
but that,
just to help myself a bit,
let me put some points in here.
So I've got one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five should really the same in your notes.
You probably have lined paper that makes this easier.
Okay.
It starts by plotting my expected payoff from choosing the strategy up.
So this isn't so hard.
We know that if I choose up and there's pro bowler cs zero that the other guy is
going to choose rights.
Right?
That's the same as saying I choose up on the other guy who chooses,
let's try again.
All right.
They,
if there's problems,
he's zero,
but the other guy chooses rights.
And that's the same as saying that the other guy is going to choose left.
Okay?
So that's,
so the problems is zero.
The other guy choosing left is the same as that.
Probably zero.
That that again,
probably zero of that.
Choosing rights is the same as saying they just,
they choose laughs.
So that might pay off from,
from ARPA gains.
That is given by the top box up there.
I get five.
All right,
so this is my payoff from choosing up against left.
Alright?
And conversely,
if there was probably one that the other guy is going to choose,
right,
and I choose up,
then I get zero.
So this point here corresponds to my pay off if I choose up and they choose
right.
And we already knew,
if I look at probably a half,
which is here
that the pay off I get from choosing the expected payoff I get from choosing up
against the half half is two and a half.
All right.
So here's a third point we can use.
Okay.
What is this graph going to look like other than these three points?
Yeah.
What's it look like other than the three points?
It's going to be a straight line.
Okay.
It's gonna be a straight line.
So you can confirm that for yourself at home.
But in fact I draw a straight line.
This will actually be correct.
So what is this?
This is my expected payoff from shooting up against the privacy of the other
person choosing rights.
And what does it actually equaled?
Sewers to confirm the equation.
It's one minus the probability that they choose rights.
In that case,
I'll get pay off of five plus that they choose,
right?
In which case I get a payoff of zero.
So it doesn't really matter.
But that's actually the equation of that line.
All right,
what about choosing middle?
Well,
once again,
we can plot that point.
So at w if the other person's choosing right with poverty zero,
that's the same as saying they're going to choose left.
And if I chose middle against left,
they get what?
I get.
One,
I should use this pointer.
I get one.
All right,
so that here,
and if I knew they were choosing right,
for sure,
that's probably one that choosing rights.
And if I choose middle,
I get four that's here.
And we've already agreed that if the,
if I think it's equally likely they're going to choose the right and left,
there's probably a half of them choosing reits.
I get two and a half from choosing metal.
So putting that all together,
I know that they must go through here again.
And once again I got a straight line.
I think I might've missed politely,
but that's more or less great.
So what is this?
This is the payoff to play a one of choosing,
middle against left.
This is the payoff to play a one of choosing.
Middle against,
right?
Right.
And the line in between this line here is the expected payoff to play a one of
choosing middle as a function of the problems that other people choose.
Rights.
How are we going to get,
and we could write down the equation.
It's going to be one minus the PO.
They shoes right times one
plus the problem to the lead shoes,
right times for one.
Again,
don't worry too much about the equation.
We're not really going to do any math here.
I'm just putting it in for completeness.
All right,
everyone following me so far?
Okay,
so let's put in now the third of these lines.
I really should use a different color already.
Let me switch colors.
Let's put in the line,
the correspondence to choosing down.
So that third line,
not to Belabor the point,
is going to go through here through four and through to
right.
So this is the payoff from choosing down against laughs.
And this is the payoff from choosing down against rights.
And I got those from looking at these payoffs here and here
and in between.
Once again,
it's a straight line.
So here's the ups,
here's the straight line,
and this line is,
let's take it out of here.
This line is the expected payoff to play a one from shooting down as it depends
on the problems that the other person chooses,
right?
Hannah?
Once again,
we can write down the equation.
It's one minus PR times four
plus PR times to alright.
And I claim that this picture really tells me everything I could possibly want
to know when my boss comes along when pressed,
when present lemon or Barry.
Now Bob has now walked in the back of the room when my boss comes along and
asked me,
why did you do that?
Right?
Why do you do that?
I can now say so for example,
okay,
just put it in these crossing points here for zone.
What I can say is if I think it's very likely,
let's call this point x.
If I think that the provost see that the other person's going to choose rights
is less than x,
then the highest payoff I can get corresponds to this line.
I have class.
The highest line on that line corresponds to me choosing up,
hey,
if I think that the problems are that they're going to choose rights is less
than x,
then my best response is to choose up.
Conversely,
if I think it's more likely than this crossing point,
why?
I think it's very likely they're going to choose,
right?
It's more likely than why the property they're going to choose,
Is More than y.
Then the highest line of the history is this one,
which corresponds to my choosing middle.
So over here,
my best response is to choose middle.
All right,
put that in.
So over here
my best response is middle,
and over here my best response is up and in between.
It's going to turn out that the highest lines of like if I,
if my belief that the person's gonna choose right,
it's is,
is more than x,
less than Y,
then my highest expected payoff comes from that Blue Line.
And in that case my best response is down.
I can rationalize all three of these decisions and hope that Barry won't fire
me.
How are we gonna do more than that?
If we're being nerdy,
but I'm not going to be this nerdy today.
What we could actually do is we could sold out,
we could solve out for the x and for the y.
How would we go about,
I mean I don't want to do it because I'll probably get it wrong,
but if I wanted to solve out for this x and the y,
since this is a QR class,
let's just talk about it a second.
How would I do it?
Somebody who's somebody who's not a math major.
Tell me how I solve out there.
Maybe the math,
I just can't do it.
Actually it's too simple.
Somebody who's a math major,
tell me how to solve out for the x and the y.
We can be,
but it's going to make on this.
This person here is that the intersection points equal the equations equal to
each other and solve good.
Good to define to solve that x x is when x is when this blue line,
this blue line equals this red,
right?
Right.
Is what we're going to do is take the equations for those two lines.
So here's one of those equations and here's the other one,
right?
Set the P and there's equations equal to X.
I got a um,
two equations in one of my own,
so I can,
I can,
sorry,
I got one equation and one unknown.
I said these two things equal to each other.
I've got one equation and one unknown so I can solve that for X.
I think I did that at home.
If you do that at home,
I think we don't trust me.
You'll find out that x is equal to a third.
It repeats again.
I know I've got some math phobics in the audience.
Let me just slow down a second.
All I'm doing here is I'm saying,
look at this equation of the pink line.
Look at this equation of the Blue Line.
X is when they cross it,
they are equal to each other.
Take these two equations,
put an equal sign between them,
replaced this PR throughout with x,
I'm going to have one equation and one unknown and that even the math phobics in
the audience did in high school.
Is that right?
All right.
Now we're going to use,
this isn't,
I'm going a bit slow here,
but I'm going to use this method next time to introduce you to the most
important class,
the most important game we're going to see in the whole course.
In fact,
it's the most important game in the world.
What is the most important game in the world,
but they don't go yet.
Don't go yet.
What's the most important game in the world?
We're going to use this idea of best response.
We're going to think about it.
We're going to learn from it in the most important game in the world.
What is the most important game in the world?
Football.
Soccer.
Actually soccer is the most important.
All right,
so we're going to,
we're going to show how this technique is going to help us shoot penalty shots
in soccer.
So before you go,
that's Barry nailed off at the back.
He has copies of the book.
It's a great book.
Go buy it from him.